killing everybody on the enemy team
single-handedly is rarely easy
but in rainbow six siege it can be
really hard
sure you can just one tap your opponents
but with destructible environments and
gadgets
there is a lot getting in the way of you
and the coveted ace
today we are ranking the top 10 aces in
rainbow six siege
history and for this list we consider
the quality of the competition
the context of the round and we're
giving out bonus points for 1vx clutch
finishes
alright enough waiting here are the top
10 aces in rainbow six siege
starting our list strong at number 10 is
a play by a man so
good at aces he literally named himself
after them
upstairs citizen nice shot there we can
quite catch that
fedex is off aces though refrag on to
kendra
oh here we go turning around the corner
and ace is
able to get a 2k there taking out saves
still a 3v3 definitely possible for the
defense can you look around and he gets
it
aces with the 3k citizen is dead and
aces is an
absolute beast cory will be shot down
it's from pi
ripsters around the corner this
nitrocell out aces is looking for the
ace all on his own that's the quad kill
now
nello so low on hp and aces is gonna
stay calm he turns around and aces
with the ace here's birthday boy
after picking off kendrew aces goes on a
tear
winning gun fights and getting creative
with a nitro cell
and with nello trapped in the sight
alone rips was kind enough to let his
teammate have the ace
pretty nice birthday present if you ask
us i mean this man is just so good
literally in my opinion the best german
player
ever mint is the kind of player who
always seems to be able to ace the enemy
team
which is why his wonder woman impression
is coming in at number nine on our list
what an absolute whirlwind
and a monster of around
this blitz shield rush into church on
clubhouse is disgusting
not only did mint destroy space station
gaming he planted the diffuser by
himself
too before clutching it out mint is
setting himself up for another rush this
time
inside of moto the c4 will come out to
counter but the emp
counters the c4 in turn mint up close
and personal with these enemies managing
to flash them but stuck at the crossfire
it's really hard to get this engagement
in his favor he will finally take out
shawla but it's his team falling one
after another
putting more pressure on mint able to
get two his last teammate though pojo at
the bottom main stairs that's three for
mint incredible pistol play
and he has the defuser going for the
plant behind black box this is the
perfect position for him to plant solo
hojo is doing his best to cover but he's
gonna lose the fight to redeemer
forcing mint into an a situation he's
gonna get the 4k
he has the mirror window and the flash
and he gets that the ice permit
and the round all on blitz you can
almost
feel the frustration as he picks space
station gaming apart
one by one from behind his shield when
mint is the last guy standing on the
enemy team
you're simply not safe
cameraman is the kind of player who
thrives on surprising the opponent and
in this quick ace
he paints cafe dostoyevsky's red stairs
even redder
with jaeger redeem the dream on the
coach yeah dude that's pretty sweet of
course he'll be working with reaper oh
yeah that's a triple for cameraman on
the red stairs
going big for his team i know cameraman
looking for the eggs today
what an ace all from the same spot
mibr just flustered on this position
and cameraman after taking a dirty 1v3
cameraman decided to just stand his
ground mibr seemed shocked when they
walked in on the carnage and
the round ended in the blink of an eye
with all five opponents
laid out near the stairs at least they
managed to keep the violence to a single
hallway
i'm sure the janitor is pretty grateful
and and cameraman comes alive
yep that was beautiful
coming in at number seven is our first
non-pro league regular season entry
but this ace from tactus in season 7 eu
relegations was too
cheeky not to include he's gonna have
only a shred of health
and bonari comes in that's a double kill
from benari he uses that smg 12
so well and he'll go for another on the
tactics but he can't connect
that's a double answered back from the
smokes of supremacy
and its tactics and alive alive who was
creeping just outside of sight we'll
need to come back in but now tactics
takes out a third
this is gonna be another clutch for
supremacy they'll need to grab the
diffuser uno has it tactics coming in
he'll get a shotgun tactic since there's
one left oh the ace for tactics
making full use of both of smoke's
weapons tactics reminded everyone that
the shotgun isn't just for drywall
and that flick back to secure the final
kill was simply
excellent and he will clutch it out all
by himself
tactics make it a name for himself
many aces feature players getting a bit
sneaky but this one from bolo
doesn't in fact his opponents know
exactly where he is the whole time
but it doesn't matter i think tsm might
overextend uh through office and out of
nowhere bolo's just
in the site what is going on how was he
even able to enter now he's got control
hopefully oh the bomb is go the bomb is
being planted out of nowhere
tsm making an aggressive rush in a rush
plant this might work out for tsm
sexy king he will take down two there
but a trade out from bolo now we stand
at a 3v3 in the post plant scenario
another one rotating down but paulie
will get one bola with three on the
round now looking for more
it's down to the 2v2 sexy cake and psk
collapsing from the blue bar in the
kitchen area
trying to bring in some yokai drones
drones in the attacking side being sent
out as well
although not spotting the yokai coming
closer and closer to jaws music
amplifies but now in the hallway that's
four for polo
will he get the ace turning the corner
after rushing onto sight winning a duel
and planting the diffuser
bolo simply just out aimed the other
team retakes are
hard but they're harder when it's bolo
with his finger on the trigger
give him the ace put it in the montage
tsm of 2-0
and number five on our list we've got an
ace that's got a bit of everything a 1v5
clutch
a dirty gunfight against three enemies
and a last second no health finish that
makes you want to say
sorry an absolutely rock solid insane
clutch
based on time and positioning and he
will put his team back in this map
but canadians got nothing to apologize
for as he makes luminosity seem frozen
in place the canadians gonna have to be
the one to change
this uh situation pushes into bathroom
gets one and a second
diffuser down canadian could win this
round if he gets the third and he does
a beautiful three piece for canadian
slash heard above
he repositions and oh doodle goes down
it's the quad from canadian only one
more for canadian to win this outright
and he gets the defuser slashdog in the
site now he will be able to plant but
this has been called out canadian is
well aware of this situation
there's only eight seconds left slash
has to go for the kill now canadians
gonna be able to win this if he just
plays it on time
and he's gonna do exactly that canadian
putting the whole damn team on your back
and clutching against five is
always hard but canadian makes it look
effortless taking number four on our
list is nello
simply saying goodbye ounce of luck
pound of skill we are in the land of the
rising sun
flynn sometimes when you ace the enemy
team you understand some of the mistakes
they made
but this ace clutch from nello shows
that sometimes even when the enemy team
plays perfectly
raw aim can carry you through if darpa
got that opening pick onto kendra as
well it could have been a huge
difference maker in keeping that intel
alive outside and there goes the first
pick now looks like it's nello
looking for the bullet holes now it will
get one though as dirt bay peeks on up
but everyone's stacking by the face
awaiting the approach for nello no
utility left diffuser in hand in a 1v3
in the midst of a crossfire gets 100
diesel in the second one
are you kidding me the 1v4
after an early round kill nello was
facing down four enemies
but somehow with god like reflexes he
flicked his way through the round
coming in at number three on our list we
have a delicious ace with a spicy finish
served up by none other than aces on
maestro
those ads's will be in vain inside of
the garage ace is flashed he's got the
lmg played up and you'll just see all
the utility from pcd will be dumped in
but asus gets one
psycho is aware that there's one playing
on stairs julia will take out neo
fighter
plant going down somewhat successfully
but no aces sees them ace he's
coming in can he get it two big kills
from aces he sees another third aces oh
my goodness
he's still got the diffuser to work
through giulio will now watch
and who's gonna prevail in this fight a
sledge versus the maestro
any intel from fnatic right now could
possibly be going
but look at this one frag grenade
remaining from giulio and he's priming
it on the diffuser he'll toss it out and
aces
will he live he'll get off the plan the
meister will shoot away at the wall
this is the bat oh my god how does this
happen
after getting an initial pick asus sees
the plant happening but
plays it smart by looking for the second
enemy on cctv
immediately forced to defend himself he
then ends the whole round with the most
unlikely shot the look on his face at
the end
says it all oh my word aces
a huge clutch and he'll get the diffuser
fanatic my
god we've had a lot of clutch aces on
this list
but our runner-up spot is going to an
ace that shows that you can speed run
rainbow six oh my goodness there is a
reason ladies and gentlemen that you
ban ying away from this man and you're
gonna see it
right there so prevalent can bring them
all the way
back from the depths of hell this ace
from hungary may be the fastest in r6
esports history
as he flashes himself into armory on
yang and ends the round in under seven
seconds launching him out he's gonna
rush straight through the hole that yeah
his ash had made two blind
trying to go for three hungry we'll get
them all looking in for four
hungry the angry hungry you are
absolutely
wild and penta bring one back
he definitely got some value from that
first candela but even after that
as his enemies closed in hungary just
rolled over nora rango
what a beast
taking our top spot is an ace clutch so
dirty that it became one of the most
iconic plays in rainbow six
and it happened all the way back in
season one
[Music]
oregon supply room is a terrifying place
to have to stand your ground alone
but nesc did it and put his team up
three to one in the final map of the
series
black dragon ended up winning this
series and went on to win latin
america's first ever pro league finals
alright folks that's our list rainbow
six siege is a game with plenty of crazy
aces so
some didn't make the cut but if your
favorite wasn't on this list then
let us know in the comments below and
while you're there don't forget to like
this video
and sub to the channel thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week
man i look so pale in obs i look
slightly
better i still look pale in the video
obviously i'm white as [ __ ] and i'm
extremely pale i still look pale in the
video but i look like a
ghost on obs i look the same shade as
this controller on obs
i could camouflage into the wall if obs
was correct on colors but every time i
look at obs i'm like why the [ __ ] do i
look like casper